الفنانه مي كساب من الاسماء الفنيه
الاساسيه في السباق الرمضاني اخر كم سنه
وحقيقه سنه عن سنه بتورينا اداء اروع من
اللي قبله هذه السنه متالقه في مسلسل جعفر
العمده الى جانب محمد رمضان وهاله صدقي
وغيرهم وبتلعب مي دور الزوجه الاولى لجعفر
العمده اللي هو محمد رمضان ننسانا طيبه
عفويه نسيني انها مشكله مع السرقه يعني
كده يعني ورغم سلسله المواقف الكوميديه
اللي بتجمعها بضرايرها لكنها في نفس الوقت
بتخوض رحله مع زوجها للبحث عن ابنها اللي
انخطف من وقت ولادته وكانت بتظنوا ميت
واللي بيفتح تويتر راح يحس كانه فتح السنه
او فتح تويتر السنه الماضيه فادي جابوه زي
ما بيقولوا يعني المنصه مليانه ارشادات
وتعليقات عالمي وموهبتها وتالقها
قصه هذا الدور
اولا شكرا على كلامك انت عارفه انت
بالنسبه لي ايه بجد انا بقولها برضو تاني
قدام المشاهدين ولما بتكلميني بحس بجد كان
في شهاده كبيره حصلت والله لو انت مذيعه
كبيره ومثقفه وصاحبه اراء ومواقف وانا
بحترم جدا شكرا يا عمري ميرسي
الورق ده استاذ محمد سامي وهو بيكتب دور
ثريا كلمني وقال لي انا بكتب ورق همم
لمحمد رمضان السنه دي وفي دور وانا بكتبه
مش لاقي اي حد في الدنيا ممكن يعمله غيرك
فانا بكتبه عشان انت اللي تعمليه
فلما اخلص الورق الورق ده جالي انا قريت
ال 30 حلقه في نفس اليوم من كتر الفضول
وكنت متفقه معاه قلبا وقالبا ان فعلا
الدور ده اتخلق لي يعني الثريا دي اتخلقت
عناني والحمد لله دخلت التصوير بالروح دي
وبس
وجسد موضوع السرقه يا يعني مش معقوله ايدك
يعني بتشيل على طول يعني وبتح سرقتي كل
المسلسل ايش الوضع معك خافي على نفسك لحسن
اسرع حاجه من الهواء
جايه لكم ان شاء الله وهتنورينا كمان انت
اصلا صحبه مع محمد رمضان اصلا اه جدا انا
ومحمد اصحاب من 13 سنه يعني واول مره
نشتغل مع بعض وبصراحه اتفاجئت جدا جدا بيه
في اللوكيشن متعاون وبيحب زمايله جدا
وبيحب كل اللي حواليه يبقوا كويسين وانا
بشوف ان دي دائما
مميزات بتكون في النجم الكبير الواثق من
موهبته فانا سعيده جدا جدا بالتعاون معاه
وعايزه ارجع لموضوع السرقه ان انا استاذ
محمد سامي اتفقنا من الاول ان هي مريضه
بالسرقه
ولازم نعمله بشكل الناس ما تنفرش منه يعني
الناس تتعاطف معاها وتضحك فحتى انا افتكر
يوم الشط بتاع الراديو ده
هو قال لي لو رجعتي عملتي الشوت ده ما
ضحكتنيش حتبقي فشلوله فقلت له ماشي فقعدت
بقى اللي هو يا رب يضحكوا فعملت الرياكشن
بتاع ان انا رجعت لورا كده ولقيت الراديو
فاحنا يعني كنا متفقين من الاول ان احنا
لازم نعمل خط السرقه ده مرضي كوميدي
بصراحه الرهيب في الدور هذا انك بتضحكينا
وبتبكينا في نفس الوقت يعني عندك لحظات
قمه في الدراما انت مش ميل شخصيه
الكوميديه ابدا انت قاصده هذا الشيء انت
عندك توجه انه مثلا خلص في السنين القادمه
يمكن تركزي اكثر في الادوار اللي هي مثلا
الدراميه اكثر اللي هي تراجيديه ممكن او
شيء زي كذا
انا انا دايما بصراحه يعني انا طمعه
شويتين انا بحب دايما الادوار المزيج اللي
فيها ده وده لان الجمهور بتاعنا العربي ما
بيحبش طول الوقت يبقى متنكد وبرضو هنضحك
طول الوقت فهاحس ان انا ما طلعتش جزء من
موهبتي للجمهور فانا الصراحه من ساعه
سرايا عابدين ومن قبلها كنت اشتغلت مسلسل
مع استاذ محمد فاضل واستاذ جمال عبد
الحميد هو اللي هم هم لفتوا انتباهي
اضافات لاستاذ عمرو عرفه طبعا ان انا عندي
الشقين دول انا لازم اخد بالي دائما في
اختياراتي ان انا اختار الدور اللي اعرف
اعمل فيه ده وده ولما جيت مع محمد ثاني
بصراحه يعني قال عني شهاده انا يعني حطاها
كده وسامه على صدري لما قالها قال ان انا
من مدرسه الاستاذ العظيم نجيب الريحاني
ودي كانت في هدف كبيره جدا على قلبي
ومسؤوليه كبيره قوي انك تعرفي تعملي
المزيج بين التراجيدي والكوميدي فانا باذن
الله هو ده ده الخط باذن الله انا همشي
عليه وهعمله لنفسي باذن الله لو ربنا
قدرني لا صراحه يعني اصلا بتسويه يعني
بشكل سهل ممتنع يعني بتنتقلي بالاثنين ما
بنحس انك بتمثلي يا ماي وهذا يمكن اروع
شيء في هذا الموضوع بس خليني كمان اقول لك
بعض الاشياء اللي الناس بيتكلموا كمان
عليها على السوشيال ميديا خصوصا كتير ناس
بقارنوا بين المسلسل وبين الحج متولي
مسلسل طبعا الراحل الله يرحمه نور الشريف
كيف بتردي على هذا الموضوع هل بتحسي فيه
تشابه
خالص لان احنا الخط الاساسي عندنا مش في
صراع الزوجات على جعفر احنا الخط كل كل
واحده فينا عندها حكايتها وعندها الصراعها
الدرامي
والحدوته الاساسيه بتاعت المسلسل كله هو
فين ابن جعفر
فعشان كده انا دايما لما الناس بتقول لي
ان انتم شبه بقى الحاج متولي وكده وانت
بقى هتبقي ماجده ذكي الحاجات بقى اللي
الناس بتقولها لي دي بقعد اقول لهم والله
صدقوني ما لناش اي علاقه خالص بالحج متولي
لان ده مش الخط الدرامي اصلا
يعني شكرا يا مي انت رديتي على كل
الانتقادات يعني كده في ضربه واحده جبتيهم
ورا بعض ههه رديتي طب انا عندي فضول صراحه
انت جالسه في السياره كما هو واضح وجالسه
يعني ما بتسوقي واضح مش في مكان القياده
مين بيسوق فيكي
اخو جوزي الصغير اه اوكي طيب تحياتنا
شبهه صح كل الناس قلت له شبهتني يا عمر هو
شبهه قوي
لانه بيشبهه احنا شفناه تحت الهوا فكنا
حلو حتى كان معايا امبارح في بنك الطعام
فطار بنك الطعام المصري فلقيت الناس داخله
كاتبه لي النهارده شفتها انا واوكا فقلت
لها الله يخرب بيتك شبهتني انت
ايوه صعب فعلا في شبه منه طب خلينا نرجع
كمان يمكن للاعمال انت لازلتي مهتمه
بموضوع الراديو
اه جدا انا لو مجاليش مسلسل اذاعي بتضايق
جدا يعني بحس ان انا مش موجوده لان
التمثيل في الاذاعه متعه كبيره وانا
متشرفه السنه دي بوجودي على الاذاعه
المصريه في شبكه البرنامج العام طول السنه
بعمل مسلسل للكاتبه اماني درغام انتاج
وزاره الشباب والرياضه
مع شباب مسابقه ابداع تحت رعايه رئاسه
الجمهوريه
ووزاره الشباب والرياضه فانا مبسوطه جدا
جدا جدا بالتجربه دي لان طول السنه بمثل
انا وسامح حسين مع الكباب دول
فالتمثيل في الاذاعه لونه تانيه كده برضه
لانك مؤثرك الوحيد هو صوتك فازاي هتوصلي
بصوتك كل المشاعر اللي انت عايزه تقوليها
فده برده زي ترينين كده حلو يعني كمان
واحده من الاشياء اللي معروفه عنك يعني
انك انت شخصيه يعني جدعه يعني وبتدافع عن
زملائك وبتاخذي مواقف وانا حبيت جدا انك
انت اخذتي موقف ودفعتي عن منى زكي لانه
تعرضت لهجوم بس من بوستر المسلسل لسه ما
نزل المسلسل ليه بتحسي بيصير هذا الشيء
انه هجوم من اسم مسلسل من بوستر عمل
اليمين ايش بيكون الموضوع
يعني احيانا بيبقى يعني احيانا بيبقى له
اتجاهين الاتجاه الاولاني اللي هو السهل
بتاع ان انا ببقى متسرع في الحكم على على
اللي انا شايفه من قبل ما اعرف ايه اللي
هيحصل فهو ده حصل فعلا ان الناس
تسرعت ودي بتهين المحجبه المحجبه وحشه كده
هي يا جماعه احنا انا انا يعني عندي وجهه
نظري احنا كلنا خدام للدراما فانا بعمل
شخصيه يعني انا النهارده في المشهد الاخير
في الحلقه الميك اب باز واتبهدل وبتاع
وساح واسود فانا انا هل انا قصدت ان انا
اطلع المحجبه وحشه بقى في الموقف ده لا في
موقف درامي انا مرتبطه بيه لازم اعبر عنه
بشكلي لان مش هقدر ده احنا كنا زمان
الجمهور بيتريق على الممثلات اللي بيبقوا
صاحيين من النوم شعرهم معمول وحطيتهم ميك
اب وبيستحمل فدلوقتي الست واقعيه جدا دي
واحده عندها حدوته كبيره قوي فطبيعي يبقى
شكلها كده ما عندهاش وقت بقى لا تحط ميك
اب ولا حتى سوري يعني تعمل حواجبها هي منى
زكي دي من المدرسه الواقعيه المفرطه فهي
بتتوحد مع الشخصيه فانا متاكده مثلا ان
منى زكي من ساعه ما ابتدت تصور المسلسل ده
لعمل الضوافرها ولا عملت حواجبها ولا
اهتمت خالص بنفسها من كتر مصداقيتها مع
الدور يا استاذه يعني طبعا طبعا استاذه
كبيره قوي فانا لقيت الناس فجاه هجوم
وهجوم وهجوم وانا الصراحه يعني انا من
معجبينها ومن تلاميذها كمان فاتضايقت قوي
عشانها لانها بجد ما تستاهلش كل الهجوم ده
ايا كان مع احترامي لراي كل البني ادمين
في اي مواقف هم حرين فيها ما بحجرش على
ارائهم بس انا بشوف انك انتقد برحمه برحمه
وبادب واحنا اولادكم يعني انا بشوف ان
الجمهور ده احنا لولاه ولا حاجه احنا
بنشتغل عشان بنشتغل عشان نساعدهم لو عملت
حاجه ضايقتك او قلت كلمه مش قصدي يعني
اعتبرني اعتبر اعتبرني بنتك وجهني
بالطريقه مهذبه هتحصلها لكن هاجمتني
بالشكل ده عمري ما هسمعه هيكون جارح صح
احنا بنبغاك تفضلي معانا يا مي هنروح فاصل
وهنرجع ونكمل معك عندنا لك كده شيء صغير
يمكن مفاجاه صغيره خليك معانا